before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
oh dear
the Daleks are revolting
all right
New Year's special it's revolution of
the dialects a title that I'm just
realizing
doesn't make a lot of sense
because the the dialects aren't
revolting like there's a skirmish
between two different kinds of dialects
but that's because
one of them is slightly too Nazi
to accept the others but the the other
ones weren't trying to revolt they
wanted to rejoin the dialects yeah
there isn't really a revolution
anyways this picks up in a like pretty
directly
off of the uh events of resolution which
should have been called resolution of
the Daleks it wasn't it should have been
but uh it picks up pretty much right
right off the bat from that
and we get this whole thing of the
transport of the remnants of the uh
casing that the reconnaissance dialect
had made for itself there's actually a
little moment that I really enjoy where
the guy who's going to be driving it and
the woman is just helping it get loaded
up they you know they're talking in
these clandestine terms like be sure you
get it straight there you know don't
stop and all this stuff and then she
just goes by the way yeah you know
about that I just like
um that said obviously he stops to get
some more tea and he gets poisoned and
then they steal the thing how did they
know he was going to stop at that one
because it's not like it was his regular
place he stopped at that specific stand
because his T ran out at that time
so did they just like did they have a
plant for every single stand along the
Route were there a whole bunch of other
ones that got the call like no he's he
stopped at number 14. the rest of you
can all go home and like why bother
poisoning him like you're on the side of
the road there was nobody else there
just just shoot him why even bother
poisoning ah whatever we've got the
return of Jack Robertson played by Chris
Noth who is an actor that I don't want
to talk about the issues with him uh off
screen uh let me just say this he is
utilized much better here than he was in
Iraqis in the UK the character works
much better I don't ever need to see him
again
and I'll leave it at that but the
character works better here because he's
he is just functioning as an
opportunistic businessman in a way that
feels less cartoonish and yes I am aware
of some of our real life business people
especially uh some of the ones that he
is appears to have based on Art indeed
cartoonish but like
could I not have to deal with that in my
shows like he just feels more like an
actual human being and this one it's
good he works better speaking of uh
returning characters whose actors I do
not want to
deal with right now uh John Barrowman
back as uh Captain Jack Harkness and yes
I am just not going to deal with the
stuff that has like I've I've done
videos like year
two I don't even know how long ago it
was now
um like when stuff first went downhill
it hasn't been great since then let me
leave it at that okay
I I'm not okay with with sort of what
he's been up to and what he's been
saying and his failure to properly
grapple with his own bad behavior but
you know what I don't want to devote
another video to that and I don't want
to sink more time of this one into it
but all right Captain Jack again like
Robertson better utilize here than the
last time we saw him he really was just
a completely pointless Easter egg in
fugitive of the Dune he did nothing as
far as the narrative was concerned here
he has a lot more impact and he gets a
chance to actually well see the doctor
for one and just have more chance to
Banter and be glib and he's really good
for that he has a an interesting
chemistry with the doctor you got to
tell at certain points that he's a
little put off at how
um at least to him to his eye I'm sure
how asexual she kind of comes across as
he's kind of like Oh I thought we were
gonna thought we were gonna like do our
flirting thing okay all right and also
like there's a moment later with Yaz
where she gets his number because he
does this whole thing with the
squareness gun she's not super impressed
and he's like that's it and she goes are
you feeling insecure
seem to need libraries and he gets nice
little moments with a number of
different characters including
um kind of being off to Graham again
um and it's it's fun
Jack is fun in this
if this is the last time we see him
which at this point I'm going to presume
it will be
it's not like a proper send-off because
it's not like fully focused on him
but it's a decent last appearance
oh uh line I really love from him is
towards the end when uh they're working
out their plan to help to deal with the
dialects just the back and forth between
him and the doctor how do you feel about
building an essay can I blow it up yes
yes it's my kind of plan that's the kind
of Jack moments I'm here for I like it
in general I kind of like the picking up
on the reconnaissance Dalek overall sort
of having this feel like a direct sequel
to the previous holiday special is act
actually I think one of the better ideas
chibinal had like his three holiday
special well New Year specials because I
don't feel like counting the um
uh uh yeah
legend of the the
sea levels that's what it was that's
what it was so non-descript my brain
melted
um legend of the sea Devils was
technically a holiday because it was
like an Easter but like the there was
sort of an informal Trilogy with
resolution revolution of the dogs and
then Eve of the Daleks and mostly with
the first two they're more directly
connected but I kind of like this thing
I like yeah there's these threads we're
gonna pick up on for just these specials
and they almost kind of form their own
little Arc in a way I would be on board
if RTD or anybody else wants to pick
that idea up and run with it to be
honest and I like the reconnaissance in
this I liked it before I like the way
that it puppets people I like the voice
that's real sense of Menace that you get
from this thing it's it's quite well
done
I will say
um
this
episode so there's a there's a moment
with the dialect that in isolation I
love and in context I kind of hate in
isolation uh the doctor is pointing out
this is right before all these things
teleport into their shells uh the doctor
because it's controlling Leo and the
doctor points out uh you don't have to
kill him
or I do not have to
get
the way that voice is done it's the way
it's delivered it's intimidating I love
it I love it but I hate it in context
because coming back to the recurrent
issue of the unnecessary cruelty
of this era
why did we have to establish earlier
that Leo has a wife and child
look we actually spend enough time with
him versus some of the other characters
that children has done this with that we
actually do have enough time to get a
sense of him as a person it's not like
you need to tack on oh has wife and
child because you had no time to give
him any personality traits it's not like
the the random guard in a resolution who
was alive just long enough to have it
point out that he was gay and was then
killed so that's literally the only
thing we know about him we got to know
Leo a little bit we got to know him
through what he did the way he
interacted with the woman who becomes
the Prime Minister and is sort of over
eagerness and how he bounces off of
Robertson like we get a sense of him as
a person so this kind of thing to try
and force an investment which never
worked anyway is deeply unnecessary and
just makes it cruel if we knew enough to
care then we care that he died making
him now someone who is leaving behind a
child and a widow is unnecessary and
cruel I think my thing with this episode
overall is that it has a lot of
potential that goes untapped
um it's not a case of like the you know
there are some of the things that are
just completely left to die like the few
good ideas that we're in Ascension of
the Cybermen or or the Timeless children
but it's rather a case of like you have
something right there that is so good
you should probably strip a whole bunch
of the other stuff out and really dig
into that and that thing is the idea of
Daleks backing up police
and it's it's clearly done on purpose
the ways in which the um prime minister
goes on about security talking about
putting these rolling tanks
on every street
to make the world safe
and like even ignoring the fact that
they don't know they're going to be
deadly they think they're equipped with
a spray hose and gas and whatnot I'm
like
that's still a weapon
that you want to put on every street and
every Port of Entry that you just want
there so people know that at any moment
violence can be enacted upon them and
you call it security
the episode knows this has meaning
it draws emphasis to her use of the word
security over and over again but it
doesn't really dig into that
I there was so much that could have been
done
to have the militarization of a police
force of what that means to do that to
truly be looked into and to be a deeper
theme than just yes that's a thing that
happens which yes it does and enough
attention is drawn to it that is clearly
not a thing that they just hit upon by
accident and didn't realize I shouldn't
have to specify that with a professional
writer but with Jim Mill I feel like
it's worth noting because it seems like
half the time stuff he does good or bad
is accidental but
there's so much more that could have
been done and like I I want a story that
explores that idea but this notion of
Daleks as police has now been burned off
and I don't know if anyone else is gonna
have the room to do anything with it
again it was a I deal with a hell of a
lot of potential in it and it's not
completely wasted some stuff is done
with it but it could have been a lot
more
I haven't really talked too much about
the doctor in the prison which I
actually kind of like it's got good
um atmosphere and mood to it and also I
just like I like the doctor you know
going through these motions saying hi to
the security cameras saying hi to
everyone and I guess what is the
equivalent of the yard but like nobody's
happy to see her she has no friends but
she's going through the motions and I
love I love when she lays down in her
bed in her cell
and is talking to herself that time
story doctor
like I I love that
I don't love that the uh bedtime story
she starts she starts to tell herself
it's the first Harry Potter book but it
is important to remember this despite
coming out
uh January 1st 2021 was
produced and written and filmed in April
of 2020.
which is before JK Rowling released her
first massive Turf essay like people
have been paying attention already knew
uh that what she was like including
yours truly but like
the point at which it became undeniable
by everyone except the people who also
share her beliefs
um yeah that hadn't happened yet so
while it hurt me to hear Jody Whitaker's
doctor recite lines from Harry Potter I
need to not hold that against it I like
that we get this kind of Glimpse that
Yaz being obsessed with the idea of
getting the doctor back while Graham and
Ryan are already trying to move on with
their lives that actually Rhymes really
well with the fact that Graham and Ryan
leave but yeah it stays behind that
actually tracks incredibly well I like
the wild first of all I like the music
but I also like the sense of pure joy on
the character's faces hearing that
Tardis sound again that's really well
done that warmed my heart I kind of
already mentioned Yaz and Jack I like
their little talk and Jack giving her
this line of you don't get to choose
when you're time with the doctor stops
and yes basically has a is it better to
love and lose than to never love at all
kind of existential moments oh speaking
of existential like there's nothing here
lingering from the Timeless child like
the dark has a token acknowledgment to
Jack that like I was uh I was arrested
for being myself at a time when I didn't
know who that was and like that line is
all the acknowledgment of the Timeless
child that we get at all
and just re-emphasizing the
pointlessness of that there's also a
pretty good conversation between the
doctor and Ryan that kind of sets up
Brian leaving but also Ryan tells the
doctor so am I done with this toilet
problem
you find out about your own life
come from the new or the old and
still not good at opening up and this is
Ryan kind of being like you're not good
at opening up even to yourself so like
get better at that at least and so again
when the show and the characters have
dealt with and acknowledged the fact
that she is very clammed up I like those
moments just in principle I kind of like
the Dalek factions fighting each other
like that's just a general concept of
that I've been wanting Doctor Who to
bring back and I still do because I
wanted them I wanted to come back in a
bigger way than this than a one-off
episode because like that's very much
something that happens with anything
with the kind of hateful ideology that
the Daleks have
fractionalization infighting deciding
that one kind of group is not actually
pure as you are like that's what happens
and I kind of would like to see Doctor
Who get back into that it was getting
into it in the classic era but it hasn't
really properly dealt with it other than
here and I do like it here but it's not
much so there's also the whole red
resolution on how the Daleks are
defeated so a couple things about this
the first is
I think it's a very clever idea
the whole thing of tricking them to just
pour their Dalek forces into this Tardis
and trap them and then get rid of them
that's a clever solution now I know a
fair number of people take issue with
this because it is established Canon
that the Tardis well any Tardis is alive
and so that does mean the doctor
killed a living thing and theoretically
possibly the only other remaining Tardis
other than maybe the Masters that's
still out there she kills it
with no acknowledgment of that
and yeah that's not great I'm not going
to go off on it as hard and that's not
because it's okay because it's really
not but the reason I'm not going to go
off on that super hard is because where
chiminal drives me crazy is when he
contradicts stuff that he himself brings
up or fails to deal with things that he
himself brings up and he has never
reiterated the idea that the Tardis is
actually alive now that doesn't mean it
isn't it isn't suddenly non-canon just
because he hasn't personally reiterated
it
um with any specific emphasis during his
time but that to me says that like he
didn't betray his own run it is a little
bit of a betrayal of how the Tardis has
been depicted and what the doctors uh
moral guidelines should be but
because he's done that so much worse in
other areas I kind of shrug this one off
which is messed up I feel like the exit
for Ryan and Graham works pretty well it
had been established that Ryan had had
like almost recurrent Nightmares of the
drags in orphan 55 which not a great
episode to have recurrent fears about
but that was established that like he is
really worried about the future of the
planet he wants to stay here and try and
make the world that he comes from a
better place and it makes perfect sense
for Graham if Ryan's going to stay he's
going to stay that's his family and I
like their moments together towards the
end them literally seeing Grace is like
a little heavy-handed but it's sweet
enough that like I don't feel like
getting mad about it and I also kind of
like that the very last image is Ryan
still falling off the bike because again
just because you've been through a lot
of stuff you don't magically not have a
disability anymore it's great that he
has grown and that's demonstrated
through the fact that he's not
complaining about and he's willingly
getting back on the bike and trying
again but you know it's good that the
last image is him falling because it's
never gonna stop being hard
that was nice so yeah I guess that's it
I I have fun with this it doesn't stand
up to a ton of scrutiny uh if you think
too much about it and there are little
moments that
um
yeah and some wasted potential but
honestly I still I stand by the idea
that
chimnal's own Scripts not the best stuff
of his era but his best stuff
is the New Year specials I think that's
his best writing that he did when he was
in charge
but what did you think of this one
Whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
link down in the description as well as
well as links to other things that I do
other ways that you can support me if
you want to help ensure that I can keep
doing this as my living and you know
feed myself and also my kid
um but even if you can't like share
subscribe help as well even if you're
not up for that it's okay too because
what I really want you to remember is
that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore zoom
in the fulla to rock the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Melinda
Walters emu dalke Leo the Boyd Becky
Sparks for nabilax the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support and if you want
to get your name in the credits check
out the rewards on the patreon
[Music]